and every single one of you can have a
life and have a great life you make your
own luck in life every time and every
entrepreneur makes it all up you must
have a product you believe in probably
it will sell for the people one if you
work hard if you deal with customers you
talk to your team that's the best way to
motivate them people are gonna help
children are gonna get married they're
gonna do a lot of things and I never
plan ahead you're the first person were
21 years and my career has ever asked me
not me though and that's me for the job
it is easy and everybody could do it
there's not many people who don't do it
anyway and one can go and start a
business
he's a Scottish entrepreneur
philanthropist and author his business
interest includes hotels health clubs
spas media TV property and
transportation he's most famous for his
appearance as a business angel on the
BBC programme Dragons Den he's Duncan
Bannatyne and here's my take on his top
ten rules for success after this moment
you get a phenomenal opportunity and
every single one of you can have a life
and have a great life and have money and
have a privileged future the only person
stopping you is you do you see luck ever
comes into it no you make your own well
you know I think you can you can you can
find someone who's sleeping in the
doorway and he was it was a very very
lucky because pastor's daughter one day
and it was empty so he's sleeping now
you make your own luck in life every
time and every entrepreneur makes her
own luck
and I don't know anyone who started out
as a businessman and not had a bit of
good luck and a bit of bad luck legal
proportions and done very well product
is a very important part of any business
you must have a product you believe in a
probable sell for the people one or in
the case of the Teutons
stage school I invested in razzmatazz
with Denise Hahn you have to have a
product or a service that people want
nah was recognized by Denise she
recognized that people wanted this type
of skills and absolutely now franchise
that and then fantastic it's a great
company when I was there I worked in a
bakery to supplement my income
ocean by the odd car - of cellar
one day I saw this beautiful Asian white
commercial for me the pilot I start
business if 450 pound for that's the
criterion this place hello what can I
get for you
just playin a strip it was here in
Stuart spark that Duncan acquired the
exclusive license to sell ice creams
this really started making businessman a
few people have got eyes it wonder wakes
up and says I'm gonna make Duncan
Bannatyne rich you've got gonna do it
yourself you're going get off your
backside and go out and actually do it
when I was here many situations are
different but the best way to motivate
your team is to lead by example if you
are early in the morning if you start
eight o'clock near that half-past seven
if you leave last then you're motivating
your team as to when to start and when
to finish if you work hard if you deal
with customers you talk to your team
that's the best way to motivate them
apply in your life plan if I mean in
business we plan for five years the
finances that people are going to have
children are gonna get married they're
gonna do a lot of things and I never
plan ahead right no sir although isn't a
plan ahead and make a business plan one
of the most important things abandon
business is the people the people that
you employ the people that ruin your
business because when you're a
successful businessman you don't run the
business you manage astir one of my most
successful guys is my Madison director
who stayed with me in a coach department
and he just Sean they develop from the
coach department to commercial director
and you know his management over the
Bannatyne group and all employees have
got the opportunity and a chance to
expand on my company if to work hard on
did thing that nobody in Britain ever
does my ex-wife and I Gail and I went
round knocking on doors asking for work
went to local bakery
I said personal manager I still retain a
job she said no when someone else has to
this layer and they interrupt in morning
the phone rang it's personal manager
from the bakery she said I've been
thinking about you she says you're the
first person but 21 years and my
career's ever asked me not the door and
asked me for a job
you'd have to go and look for employees
so she referred to jobs where the morph
and I but it wasn't always a time which
side and the bakery my job was to get
the bread traces to come out the bread
hurry and put them on the vines my
girlfriend's job was to get the cherries
and put them on the big wall tarses that
came through the system it's a bit
monotonous but warned 8:00 shift what's
all over the time got the payroll up and
my ticket mortgage the organizational
structure it's very important whether
you have a pyramid structure where you
have a lot of regional managers and then
report to another manager and above them
or whether you just have a Lane
management it doesn't matter
ever works for you whatever works for
the business depends on the business
it's the best thing to do but you must
have a structure that works a finance
department over here management
department here the most are we will
come together and run a business
otherwise you don't have a business I
think I say this is your third book I
mean the first one was anyone can do it
the second one was wake up and change
your life how to be smart with your
money
it kind of makes it sound easy but it's
it's not that easy as it or everyone
would be doing it it is that easy
everybody could do it there's not many
people who are doing do it anyone can go
and start a business I mean you know a
successful business you know I was not
educated I left school at 15 I joined
our own Navy I got Shawn out when I was
an 18 year old I spent six months in
clink I spent a few days but a linear
later on few years layer I couldn't go
job a certain business because it
couldn't go job and I was 29 - that was
another 29 and I started the business I
mean your story is well documented and
you've you know summarized are very well
there and it fascinates me I mean
basically up till 30
when you were a bit of a bum and I see
them in the Scottish I know what I mean
we know what you mean and then within
seven years you were a multi-millionaire
what did you start doing differently you
must have start to do something
differently well I started in business
by selling ice cream
I never bought the opposition ban and I
bought three more bands and I went from
there and then I decided that was gonna
be a national business me back law and
to build a brand new nursing home be
single bedrooms miss I sold everything I
sold my house my color television my
scream business my car everything in
mortgages a lot of money and credit
cards and you and the National Murdoch
was opening but worth more where it cost
no Wars no paid off on the desk
that was it I still think something must
have clicked in your head
does it help having nothing to lose yeah
absolutely yeah cuz you say you know you
sound best you sold that and but if you
if you've got a family already and
you've got and you're one of these
people who's been brought up to scrimp
and save and you've got lots of
dependents then you've got too much to
lose to take the risk
yeah if you read the dr. Vargas is a LOF
entrepreneurs successful
entrepreneurship see their most timid no
education no best governor so they
couldn't be jobs as the countin circus
bank managers unshielded thousand point
a year bankers and scissor so they had
no choice either they stand business or
they got a job sweeping the streets or
something okay job but all the same so
thank you so much for watching i made
this video because joshua McNulty asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what your Duncan's
top ten rules had the biggest impact on
you what change you're gonna make now in
your business as a result leave it in
the comments and I will join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon